today I'm going to talk about invisible
problems every society is plagued by
problems that are particularly hard to
solve precisely because nobody can see
them so to give you an example the
ancient Greeks were remarkable
innovators both in politics and in the
sciences but even the most enlightened
thinkers of the day thought that women
were inferior to men and that slavery
was actually good for slaves
so in our day were confronted with a
host of difficult problems poverty
violence environmental and financial
catastrophes I believe these problems
are caused in part by a deeper form of
inequality than the one that plagued the
Greeks and until we can all see this
root cause clearly we're going to
struggle to solve our more serious
problems so the root cause is very
simple so we underestimate ourselves I
first saw this through my own experience
I'm a mathematician and playwright but
when I was growing up I had deep doubts
about my abilities these were confirmed
when I almost failed my first calculus
course at university fortunately I was
saved by the bell curve that brought my
mark up to a c-minus but unfortunately I
also got the lowest mark in my creative
writing class so when I graduated from
university I didn't think there was too
much I could do it took me a long time
to develop the confidence to go into
these fields and fifteen years ago I
started a charity in my apartment called
jump math because I didn't want kids to
struggle in math the way I had jump
produces materials for students training
and resources for teachers and our
student books are used by a hundred and
fifty thousand children now in Canada in
the u.s. we also participate in rigorous
research including two randomized
controlled studies so to give you an
idea of the extent to which we
underestimate ourselves I'd like to
start with a case study
at the beginning of grade five honto
public school teacher mary-jane Moreau
tested her children on a test called
automa a standardized test of
mathematical ability and the average
mark in the class was in the 54th
percentile there was quite a range of
marks the lowest mark was in the tenth
percentile and the highest mark was in
the 75th percentile so I've seen this
same range in all of the schools I
visited this would represent about a
three grade level difference between the
top students and the bottom students as
early as grade five so Mary Jane tried
using the jump lesson plans for a year
and she retested her kids at the
beginning of grade six and that's what
the bell curve looked like the lowest
mark was in the 95th percentile and the
average was in the 98th and at the end
of grade six all but one of the students
wrote the Pythagoras math competition
and 14 of the 17 got Awards of
distinction and the other three came
close now this is just a case study but
in a much larger randomized controlled
study students in jump classes
progressed at twice the rate of the
control group and there's a growing body
of evidence in cognitive science that
virtually every child is born with the
capacity to do well in any subject so
the question is why don't we see these
kind of things in our society there are
many reasons but I'm going to focus on
four first until recently there haven't
been many rigorous studies in math
education some people have argued that
kids should be allowed to discover
things on their own and others that they
should be taught more explicitly a new
body of research in cognitive science
suggests that a balanced approach called
guided discovery produces the best
results so in guided discovery children
are given opportunities to discover
things for themselves but the teacher
carefully guides their learning by
providing lots of feedback practice
review by breaking problems into more
manageable steps so if you're interested
in this research you can find a summary
in an article
for Scientific American mind at jump
math org now it's very important that we
pay attention to this research in
education because we're often swayed by
arguments that aren't founded in very
solid data or evidence so for instance
some people argue that because we have
the internet kids don't learn to need to
learn facts now they need to learn how
to find and analyze facts now there's
some truth to this but research suggests
that kids who don't know basic facts
like multiplication tables often
struggle to become good problem solvers
their memories are constantly
overwhelmed trying to remember the facts
and they have trouble making predictions
and seeing patterns so recently I tried
a lesson on multiplication with a grade
three class using some charts I'm going
to show you I was very surprised the
kids managed to work through seven of
these charts in one lesson and
afterwards I found out that some of them
were only in grade two so I hope you'll
do as well as he's great to students so
I asked the kids to write the first
three multiples of three in a row like
this and then put the rest underneath
and add zeros the kids very quickly saw
a pattern in the tens digits and also in
the ones digits now they saw lots of
other patterns but I don't have much
time today so maybe you can think about
those on your own maybe when you go home
or having trouble sleeping so after a
little practice the kids were able to
write out these charts from memory using
the patterns they found and then I told
them to think of the touch pad on a
phone if you know the position of the
numbers on in the chart then you know
how to multiply by three so for instance
the number 18 is in position six and six
times three is 18 and the number 24 is
in position eight and eight times three
is twenty-four
now I'm a mathematician but I didn't
realize until a few months ago that if
you put other odd numbers like seven and
nine or the multiples in rows of three
like this you see similar patterns and
if you put the even the multiples of
even numbers in rows
five you see lots more patterns now if
this was a grade three class some of you
might already know your times tables I
know there's a lot of physicists here so
I expect that's the case and some of you
might be very good at seeing patterns so
how can I keep you engaged in the lesson
well the beautiful thing about
mathematics is that if you if you know
the math you can always create bonus
questions that don't introduce new
skills or topics but that look harder so
a good bonus question here would be can
you see any patterns that are common to
all of the charts if you look at the
tens digit for instance you'll notice in
the chart four to the tens digit
increases by one in the chart for four
it increases by two in the chart for six
it increases by three and so on
the tens digit always goes up by half of
what you're multiplying by now the
really exciting thing and I've seen this
with thousands of students is that when
students who are initially slower see
that the extra work is possible that
they can do it they start speeding up
dramatically so they can get their bonus
questions so we don't have to hold back
faster students to close the gap
Maryjane's results showed this very
clearly now these are fairly simple
charts but you can teach much more
complicated things using guided
discovery even problem solving but to
teach this way you have to know the math
well so this coming to a second problem
in education teachers are my absolute
heroes but many teachers will admit that
they don't know the math and they don't
love teaching it at a teachers
convention I asked a large group of
teachers why when you divide seven by
two-thirds you can flip and multiply and
someone yelled out because you get the
right answer so that's true to give
teachers the professional development
they deserve in mathematics can be very
expensive so a jump we decided to take
the expertise of a team of
mathematicians and expert teachers and
put that knowledge into clear
comprehensive lesson plans so that
teachers can learn the math as they
teach it if you register at jump math
org you'll find lessons for Kanda
the US common core even even a video
that explains why you flip and multiply
now a third a third reason we struggle
to teach math well is because we think
it's an inherently hard and boring
subject now you wouldn't think that
learning to read numbers is very
exciting but listen to these grade two
students three three hundred fifteen
thousand four hundred unbelievable okay
like I really wasn't planning good so I
think we have to go up the billions
billions all right this is the last one
okay anything to give to millions yeah
who thinks they can do billions yeah you
think you could do it I I think you
could do it what do you think you want
to try it so you did it that's fantastic
okay I got you guys I can't really visit
any harder I could go to trillions yeah
so I've seen that same kind of
excitement at every grade level I've
seen kids cheer for math and I've seen
them beg to stay for recess I even broke
up a fight once by telling the bully
that if you didn't apologize I wouldn't
give him this bonus question
and he apologized and this brings me to
my last and only radical point we're
confronted with a circular problem in
education we teach math and other
subjects in a way that causes many
students to struggle and this reinforces
our belief that only a few are born with
ability but what if this belief itself
was the main cause of our problem as
early as grade 1 children start
comparing themselves to their peers and
deciding who's smart and who's dumb in
subjects like math once children have
decided they're not talented their
brains stop working efficiently they
stop persevering paying attention they
even develop anxieties and behavioral
problems but teachers like Mary Jane
have shown that we don't have to teach
this way once you've seen how much
children can learn and how much they
love learning you have to admit that
we're living in an age of intellectual
poverty if children are born with
anything it's a sense of the invisible
beauty of the world they love seeing
patterns making connections solving
puzzles as you can see from this lesson
of children learning about of all things
binary codes but the majority will lose
this sense of wonder and curiosity
before they grow up because as a society
we expect so little of ourselves every
child has a right to fulfill their
intellectual potential just as they have
a right to develop healthy bodies and we
don't have to wait until we've invented
some miraculous new technology or
discovered a new method of teaching to
guarantee this right we could accomplish
more now as a society than all the
towering geniuses of the past 4 if we
were merely to educate our children
using methods based on rigorous
evidence we would be the last generation
whose promise is lost
thank you